jojo was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute meine freunde gucken wir uns
wieder kommentare an und zwar diesmal
von babys beauty palace ich kann euch
sagen leute das war schwierig warum
sieht er jetzt so ich habe mir ein bild
angeschaut hier sind baby und julian
roberts verliebt sich später das war die
hölle wirklich ich hab echt probleme
gehabt verwendbare kommentare zu finden
weil ihr seht ihr like-for-like wird
verlost like-for-like fff las fallas lfl
cfcl f cell mlc fcl flf mffc fdj die
leute übertreiben komplett haben
irgendwelche wörterbücher mit
abkürzungen wie sie sich gegenseitig
follower lutschen könnten ja auf jeden
fall richtig krass dann habe ich so
weiter geschaut was gibt es sonst noch
so
sodann habe ich ein bisschen weiter
geschaut und hier gefunden lf lf lf lf
eine ganze seite habe ich nochmal weiter
geschaut fff flf leute es geht die ganze
zeit so ist es wirklich schlimm toya da
ist das bild das wir gerade eben schon
gesehen haben da ist der kommentar dazu
der passende immer dieses lfl fff und
cfc könnt ihr nicht einfach einen
kommentar zum bild da lassen wirklich
bridge sie hat gesagt oder er hat gesagt
der oder diejenige die das geschrieben
hat hat einfach recht ich habe es auch
bei sowas den namen nicht zensiert weil
ich meine das ist ja keine negative
aussage ja sehr wichtig auf jeden fall
selbst sozusagen so und dann kamen wir
beim selben bild ein kommentar von craft
der krankhaft was hast du dir für hosen
twitter an also man sieht auf jeden fall
die fans von mir und luca den sehr
freundlich und machen sich einfach
lustig sie unmöglich sollte bitte seid
seid auch respektvoll im umgang mit
anderen youtube ok jetzt geht aber erst
richtig los ja wir haben dieses foto von
bibi und julian wo sie sich gegenseitig
ablenken könnte man sagen und die
kommentare sind göttliche 100 da sie
täglich aus und dann schreibt caro habt
ihr eure zungen aneinander ist ja
widerlich und bio niemann ich habe
keinen profit skript leicht übertrieben
also sie machen halt ein foto ist halt
blöde halt so ein bisschen rum
es ist ja cool so in der beziehung macht
man das seien aber die reaktionen sind
einfach der hammer so als hätten sie
irgendwie grad nacktfoto zusammen
hochgeladen oder so aber sie berühren
einfach nur ihre zum miteinander jemand
ich hab keinen porno stars gefolgt und
hier geht es noch weiter hier schreibt
mehr sie täglich ihr habt eure zungen an
zunge die leute regen sich darüber auf
als wäre es das schlimmste vor
der welt das wird wahrscheinlich daran
liegen dass sie ein bisschen jünger sind
die zuschauer aber hier geht's einfach
noch weitere kommentaren zum beispiel
schreiben amina arminia tiki
küstenmacher zensiert pervers ist es
schon recht lustig finde die reaktion
würde ich total cool deshalb mir gedacht
schaue ich mir doch die amina mal an
jetzt bin ich auf den oft das profil
gegangen und wirklich leute gleich kommt
was bin ich nicht darauf klar gekommen
so sie schreibt hier herz an alle die
mir folgen und prostitution
naja so normale kinder instagram post
würde ich sagen ist auch nicht so alt
und dann gucke ich weiter und hat sie
halten foto also die linke sie mit einem
kleinkind und also ich würde sagen das
mädel ist 12 11 oder sowas um den dreh
und heimlich weiter geschossen dann sehe
ich das hier seht ihr das hier oben
links einfach ein kind mit einer kippe
im mund und g aufspielt drauf und die
ami natsuki hat einfach ein foto gemacht
hat wo sie einem kleinen kind eine kippe
in den mund gesteckt hat und smog wetab
whitaker geschrieben hat ich fühle mich
ein bisschen schlechter sich darüber
lache ich meine warum steckt man im baby
ne kippe in den mund macht davon noch
ein foto über dieses also wirklich ich
habe echt das foto gesehen dafür ist
also wirklich keinen kopf gefasst wie so
steckt man einem kleinen kind eine kippe
in den mund also ich meine auch wenn sie
nicht angezündet ist das ist doch
einfach ist auch kein schönes foto von
so ein kleinkind mit einer zigarette mit
vor der likes wird sie auch selbst ihr
foto geliked und ja also wirklich dafür
so ok scheiß drauf fossey einfach ein
foto von dem baby mit einer kippe im
mund der untertitel smog wie häufig so
unter dem foto habe ich noch ein
bisschen weiteren getrieben weil es war
halt super lustige sachen darunter melek
schreibt ich liebe jeden der lebt ich
denke so okay dass auf jeden fall eine
sehr positive lebenseinstellung melek
feiere ich und dann mich auf mexiko und
gegangen weil ich wollte so quasi so ein
bisschen nach den ursachen forschen so
warum ist man so happy warum liebt man
jeden erlebt und dann war es natürlich
klar
melek ist richies [ __ ] und gönnt sich
die 20 euro scheine schaudert mein onkel
melek und auch die unterschrift wieder
lecker 20 euro richtig gut ist es
einfach lustig was man so viele leute in
den kommentaren findet ist immer ein
bisschen arbeit zu recht zu
recherchieren und zu zensieren
aber ist absolut lustig und ich hoffe
mal dass das video auch wieder gefällt
das letzte video kann mir übertrieben
gut an und schauen wir weiter so dann
ist dieses foto von der pizza challenge
und ich dachte mir schon wieder okay ich
bin bei katja krawiec in den kommentaren
weil riehl irgendwas schreibt mir für
einen ding dong bild am besten snaps
könnt auch videos haben egal
das ist einfach foto von der pizza
challenge und wie ihr vielleicht gesehen
habe die anderen leute die kommentieren
sind so ungefähr zehn elf und so und das
ist jetzt wirklich nichts wie bei katja
krasavac wo man zumindest davon ausgeht
dass die zuschauerschaft ein gewisses
alter erreicht haben sollte weil dieser
content den baby produziert ist ist ja
wirklich auf kids ausgelegt also diese
changes und sowas und dann da so ein
kacke hin zu schreiben also finde ich
schon echt grenzwertig dann lieber noch
für katja casa witze aber krass fand ich
es auf jeden fall auch also auch die
werden davon nicht verschont leute ja
gut ich wollte mir die typen einmal
anschauen aber leider noch nichts
gepasst wird also vielleicht so einfach
einen thron ich weiß es nicht aber ja
krass auf jeden fall nächstes foto naja
was was sollen es schon für kommentare
seien lf lf lf lfl aber alina schreibt
ihr seid pervers aber ich liebe babys
also wirklich wo die sich mit erzogen
ablecken ok aber was zur hölle ist an
diesem foto verwehrt erhält sie einfach
nur leute was ist daran verwerflich ist
einfach stinknormales foto sie haben
einfach diese kette will forever be foto
gemacht und alina findet das pervers
okay jetzt geht's richtig down nochmal
goes down in the commons nicht unter die
ems egal und zwar schreibt gala unter
dieses bild von baby du blöde [ __ ] du
blöde kröte daggi ist besser als du
what the [ __ ] alter wieso muss man leute
zu beleidigen nur weil man einen
youtuber besser findet und dann habe ich
hab ich mir natürlich dass das profil
angeschaut von gala und trommelwirbel es
ist ein kleines kind voll kongress also
warum hat man im alter von elf jahren
irgendwie so viel hass für youtuber
übrig wirklich mal was ist muss das
problem so und dann gucke ich weiter
also hier sieht man eine unglaubliche
variabilität am fotos unterschiedlichen
posen unterschiedlicher belichtung
instagram feed wie er sein muss leute
bei gala läuft auf jeden fall übel da
haben wir dieses foto von dem ich beauty
palace an
und ratet mal wenn wir hier in den
kommentaren finden wirklich satt zufall
ich hab nach anderen lustigen
kommentaren gesucht es ist wieder gala
und zwar schreibt sie diesmal perverse
[ __ ] mit sch dann schreibt irgendwas
nicht lernen schreiben kleinkind gala
ich kann schreiben du dumme kuh und
impossible girl korrigiert sie hier dann
final wie kannst du nicht also wirklich
gala ist auf jeden fall voll am start
das sind wirklich vorwiegend die
kommentare gut es gibt noch ein paar
fanpages aber wirklich 90 prozent sind
like-for-like dass sie nun übertrieben
daran gibt es einige leute die hat
irgendwie schwachsinn schreiben sowie
die party ich jetzt gezeigt habe und
andere sind halt irgendwie so hörcher
baby jackson ab ja leute das war's dann
auch vom nächsten youtuber kommentare
wieder diesmal baby und ihr sonst noch
mal so einfach diesen ist wenig sagen
klischee youtube an aber irgendwie so
abholt oder so was sehen falls ja lasst
es mich wissen
ihr könnt auch mir auf instagram folgen
da packe ich euch den link mal ganz oben
in die beschreibung und da war es schon
heute
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen macht's
gut